This can be interesting.
A door not gone terribly wrong.
Tonight, new details
in the case of a man accused
of shooting a 16 year old
who mistakenly rang his doorbell.
Let's just get right into this, Chad,
right off the bat.
Tell me how big of a
part of your job
actually is knocking on people's doors?
If I was to put it in percentage wise,
I would say about between 20 and 30%.
A lot of realtors choose not to do it
because of situations.
And as soon as I knock on a door,
I always step off the porch
or try to give at least six feet
between the doorstep and myself.
No, it's interesting hearing you do that.
We do the exact same thing.
And really the key for me
is I want to be able to look to my left
and look to my right
and see that
I have space to potentially jump out of
the way if somebody comes out
with a gun.
I try to be as loud as I can.
Like a delivery. Good morning, you know.
Good afternoon.
Good evening.
Delivery from the bottom of the stairs.
Like, I try to, like, attract
attention to myself
in a way
that's, like, disarming in my mind.
Yeah.
You're just trying to let them know
that if you see someone
walking up in the next
few seconds, I come in peace.
I'm a I'm
a bike messenger in San Francisco.
I was accosted by somebody
in a nice neighborhood.
Nice neighborhood.
I wanted gamification.
Who are you?
Why do I.
Why do you think that?
I have to answer questions?
Don't think I don't know why
you came over here and stop me.
Because you think I belong
in another neighborhood, right?
At first,
he is going to call the cops
because he thought
I was stealing packages.
And then after I, you know,
I pressed him back a little bit.
He he said that I was being threatening
and that I was scared.
You know,
a lot of these people say
they do feel unsafe
and they do feel like
they perceive somebody as a threat.
But if you perceive somebody as a threat,
why not just call the police?
Why not let them?
I mean, that's what we pay them
for, right?
If I don't know
too much about the neighborhood,
I probably won't go
there and introduce myself.
I have the luxury
of picking and choosing.
Unfortunately, these gentlemen
do not do Ontario.
All of this makes me think
of a little bit of your situation,
and I know you can't talk
too much about it,
but you've been actually shot
at on the job. Yes, sir.
I always feel like my press ID.
I feel like it helps me.
It makes people calmed down.
They ask, who are you? What do you do?
And I can say, Oh, I'm with CNN.
Do you feel like your uniform
protected you in some cases?
No, sir, because I had it.
I had my uniform on day night.
Like for a uniform, big jacket,
big words, everything.
I looked up
report shooting
because I forgot the kid's name
for a second, you know?
It wasn't the first time.
How do you teach your kid?
Like, don't make a mistake.
Don't knock on the door.
Don't deliver a package.
Don't look the way you look. What?
What are you supposed to tell them?
You know,
we've gotten to a place
where you
shoot first and ask questions later
that that's that's just a terrible place
that we're headed in.